dieser asteroid hätte eine katastrophe
auslösen können eigentlich hat die nasa
das im griff jedes objekt das der erde
zu nahe kommen könnte wird registriert
und verfolgt wir wissen so von jedem
objekt das auf die erde stürzen könnte
jetzt wissen wir dass wohl doch ein
riesenbrocken durchgerutscht ist und
dieser brocken hat eine ganz besonders
vernichtende eigenschaft klicks zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science - aber nicht den kanal
und aktive die glocken und damit
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen rund 2000 hast du ihnen die
potenziellen mit der erde kollidieren
könnten kennt die nasa eigentlich trägt
sie ständig den nehmen wir fast alle
datenquellen zusammen eigentlich könnte
ihr kein asteroid entgehen eigentlich
denn genau das ist jetzt passiert die
absolute und folgende meldung
man ist morgens vermutlich
berichterstattung darüber geben wird
mache ich sie darauf aufmerksam dass ich
etwa 30 minuten 1 57 bis 130 meter große
asteroid die erde mit gerade einmal 0,1
neumond entfernungen passieren wird das
meldete lindley johnson
der mann der dafür sorgen soll dass die
nasa alles im griff hat quasi ein
planetarische verteidigungs offizier in
der meldung an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der nasa heißt es weiter
2009/10 ob er wurde vor etwa 24 stunden
entdecken das ist sehr beunruhigend denn
wenn solche asse ii nie so spät entdeckt
werden dann bleibt überhaupt keine zeit
mehr
nach dem jetzigen stand der technik die
katastrophe zu verhindern
denn die hätte 2009/10 ok verursacht da
hast du in 2009/10 ok raster am 25 juli
extrem dicht an der erde vorbei der
brocken hatte eine distanz zur erde von
nur rund 65.000 kilometer hat also
weniger als ein fünftel der entfernung
zwischen erde und mond astronomisch
gesehen ist das extrem nah internen
dokumenten buzzfeed vorliegen belegen
dass die nasa von dem asteroiden
vollkommen überrascht wurde eben 24
stunden vor der beinahe kollision wurde
der hast du ihn entdeckt und die
entdeckung machte er nicht
eine eher unbedeutende sternwarte in
brasilien spürte 2009/10 ok auf dieses
objekt ist durch eine ganze reihe
unserer fangnetze gerutscht schreibt ein
nasa experte wenige tage nach dem
knappen vorbeiflug die papiere diba
suite vorliegen insgesamt sind es 176
seiten zeigen eine überforderte
raumfahrtbehörde
ich frage mich wie oft diese situation
schon passiert ist das steht weiter in
den dokumenten und es war ein
ungewöhnlicher ein außergewöhnlicher
astrid übrigens scheint 2009/10 okay der
mit abstand größte aktuell zu sein der
im letzten jahrhundert so nah an der
erde vorbei gekommen ist schrieb lindt
leben und der asteroid hatte eben ein
erschreckendes potenzial ein asteroid in
dieser größe gilt als city killer 1
stand keller seinen druckwelle hätte ein
gebiet mit einem durchmesser von etwa 80
kilometern zerstört berlin wäre durch
einen solchen einschlag total verwüstet
worden keine schönen aussichten dass
solche asteroiden aus dem nichts
auftauchen und dieses
zerstörungspotenzial haben drohen dazu
jeden einschläge das wird passieren hier
in diesem video gibt es mehr infos über
die folgen eines solchen anschlags
anklicken anschauen und natürlich wenn
es bisher noch nicht gemacht haben
sollten sich ganz gekommen vorstellen
stück science fiction abonnieren bis
dann